warum hat der tier überhaupt seine
pflegerin attackiert darüber möchte ich
jetzt sprechen mit der tiger expertin
karen oppel sie ist märz live
zugeschaltet guten abend frau oppelt wie
erklären sie sich diesen tödlichen
tigerangriff tiger gehören zu den
gefährlichsten raubtieren überhaupt und
das problem ist dass sie eben auch sehr
territorial sind sie sind einzelgänger
in der regel und die pflegerinnen die
sich dort im gehege aufgehalten hat ist
ganz einfach einen eindringling gewesen
für diese tigerdame und unter umständen
auch gefahr ihr das revier streitig zu
machen
würden sie also sagen das verhalten war
natürlich oder hat auch die situation in
der sich der tiger da befand also diese
situation was damit zu tun die zu
situationen kann sicherlich mit dazu
beitragen aber auch tiere die in der
gefangenschaft geboren wir haben
behalten natürlich ihre natürlichen
instinkte und das jahr verhalten ist
einfach ein angeborenes verhalten wird
somit in meinen augen ein instinktives
natürliches verhalten von dieser
tigerdame eindringen zu töten
anzugreifen
das heißt das alter der tigerdame sie
war habe ich gerade mal oder ist gerade
mal vier jahre alt spielt auch keine
rolle
das denke ich eher nein
ab dem ersten lebensjahr fragen tiguan
zu jagen und wie gesagt das verhalten
ist absolut natürlich dankeschön karen
oppelt für ihre einschätzungen vielen
dank